a hopeful virus with bobbi and kalila or
before you go I'm sorry can we talk
about the UFC after I just threw this
okay go okay this is from Twitter from
at bag of emotions how do I keep pushing
through life when the universe
constantly hands you setbacks are we too
dependent on time how does one keep
going broad broad no I got the specific
thing right and I really mean this less
is more less is more
don't want it don't want good things did
you know a minimalist take you know mean
live simply right dream big
visualize you really have to visualize
because I'm going to tell this right now
and ask anyone in this room ask anyone
in the comedy industry who's the latest
laziest one right here I haven't done
anything
I knew has a network if you should know
that's not what I'm saying I'm just
saying that I've been able to survive
because I closed my eyes right
no I mean over the way no I know I'm
doing it now right I closed my eyes and
I envision like you know being I don't
know why but I think how do me Awards
and then I go hey Daniel he turns around
and goes and now Daniel day-lewis
oh the Daniel Craig or whatever either
one he goes that and then like just
being you know I may never get there I
think one day at one time I'll be in a
fluke thing why not you know and they're
gonna be like he got nominated or
something and then we show up and it's
gonna be a fluke but I visualized it and
I really believe it and you can laugh
all you want right now I know people are
laughing like [ __ ] you was never gonna
happen it may not but what I'm saying is
is that I have these fantasies
I really do I fantasize about things all
the time and I believe in a you know I
just try to touch and feel the you know
where I'm at
but you also go to work what I mean
you're the laziest person but you make
your it's wrong to say just fantasize
and wait for things to fall in your lap
because you go out there you go to
auditions you work hard even though you
are lazier than the bunch
you still go and show up to work so show
up to work
yeah you can't just not do something I
know but just deal I don't happen no but
still it's like you do the minimal thing
of showing up and then you dream big
next question
yet more quick one more quickly I have
another sister both you guys from at
warm slide on Twitter look I want to
become a hipster and yet be attractive
to a certain Korean chick how do I go
about it is that even possible he wants
to be honest I want to become a hipster
and yet be attractive using either a
hipster no because there are a lot of
[ __ ] fake hipsters they run around
just dying but would you what do you
define as well hipster like stir starter
kits I mean come on no he's not he
doesn't dress he's a hippie intellectual
redneck that's my new branding I
could've out of my [ __ ]
and I would pick up that vomit I mean
how was that Saturday I mean look at he
didn't go on to this guy work slide yeah
what do you think why would you need to
turn yourself into something simply to
attract a woman like if you can't be
yourself and think you can pull hair
like you're you're already on starting
off on the wrong foot be yourself
[ __ ] [ __ ] the labels don't need to be
anything but yourself and try to get her
that way more is less apparently
[Music]